This Mother's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. That's right. Mother's Day is almost here. It is Sunday, May 11th. Wow, that just really snuck up on me. It's like all of a sudden it's here. What are your plans? Well, I'm taking my mom to New York
for a little Mother's Day celebration. How fun. Pre-Mother's Day, yes. She has always wanted to visit Ellis Island to see her grandmother's name on the log there. That is gonna be so moving. I know, it was one of her bucket list items in life and this year I'm making it happen.
Oh man, I love that. Well, you know, we usually take my mom out to lunch for Mother's Day, my sisters, you know, they all live near her. And this year I'm actually gonna be traveling to see her just a few weeks after Mother's Day. So I'm gonna to miss that lunch, but we have a FaceTime hangout planned so I can sort of be with them. Oh, I love that. A virtual hangout. Yeah. Well, Lee asked me what I might like to do to celebrate Mother's Day. And I said I want a fancy tea.
I love a fancy tea. Now that I can eat gluten again, it's like literally the first thing I wanted. Because I did not miss much being gluten-free. I was fine giving up pasta and I was even okay giving up a lot of bread. Yeah. But I really missed being able to do a high tea. I mean, high tea is all gluten, basically. It's so fun though. So I'm having high gluten for Mother's Day.
What about you? Do you have plans? Well, you know, the last few years, me and my tennis scouts do a Mother's Day doubles little tournament. Oh, yes, I knew this. Isn't that so fun? Yes. And then we have brunch right after everyone brings something.
And then in the afternoon, I spend that time with Josh and the kids and I love to garden. We usually have a huge dinner. Josh makes a big dinner and he always gets me a plant because I love plants. And then him and the kids usually pick out one gift that I don't know what it's going to be. Just like a little surprise. They're really sweet about it. The kids all make me cards.
And this year, Josh was like, do you have your eye on anything? And I said, actually, I would love some perfume. I'm like out. I have like these little tester tubes. I'm weirdly into perfume all of a sudden now again too. Yeah. What's that about? I love a scent.
I don't know. Maybe it's ladies of a certain season. I don't know. But I love Jo Malone and Macy's carries Jo Malone. And sometimes they do like a fun bundle where you get the little perfume and a candle. Oh. Yeah.
That's very nice. Well, Lee also asked me what I wanted as a gift this year. He actually bought me a couple books and I accidentally opened the package when it arrived. So I spoiled that one and I couldn't think of anything I wanted. So I went to the Macy's Mother's Day gift guide. It's so great. It is. And they have a tab called Lux Gifts.
And I was like, tell me more. I might like a Lux gift. So I was scrolling through and I found this really cute gold tone stainless steel bracelet watch from Coach. It has like little blue flowers on the face. Here, let me show you. I just kind of fell in love with it. Oh, you have a picture? Look at that. That is so like cute. On the face. Here, let me show you. I just kind of fell in love with it. Oh, you have a picture?
Look at that. That is so like cute and dainty. That's what I got. So I sent Lee the link and I hope I get it. Well, you know, Macy's is having a sale right now with 25% off Mother's Day gifts. Oh, I know, I told Lee you can get 25% off this watch. Did you send Josh the perfume link?
I did. And you know, what I also love about Macy's Mother's Day gift guide is there are sections. You can do $25, $50. Like there's so many options. I know. I hope I get my perfume. I love it.
Save an extra 25% off on gifts for mom this Mother's Day. Shop the Mother's Day gift guide now at macy's.com slash gift guide. Sale runs May 6th through 11th. From early morning workouts that need a boost to late night drives that need vibes, a good playlist can help you make the most out of your everyday.
And when it comes to everyday spending, you can count on the PC Insider's World Elite Mastercard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. With the best playlists, you never miss a good song. With this card, you never miss out on getting the most points on everyday purchases. The PC Insider's World's Elite MasterCard,
the card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories.
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everyone. Hi. Welcome to Office Ladies 6. Hi. Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We have a great guest joining us today. This is one of our most requested guests. And we have been trying so long.
There's been lots of scheduling things and it finally happened. Today we are going to be speaking with Lindsay Broad, who played Kathy Sims, and she's going to talk all about her time on the show. Well, you know, Lindsay joined the show in season eight. She was in a total of 12 episodes, and we all know how much everyone loves Jim and Pam. So the character of Cathy really made some people prickle. But I found an article on Collider Lady
that gave a different perspective on the role of Kathy and what she gave to the show. Oh, I would love to hear that. It said, Kathy might have gotten between Jim and Pam, but she's a great character because she brings out the best in everyone. We get to see just how loyal Jim is. The honeymoon stage for Jim and Pam is long over, and the two are now busy every day with kids, yet Jim never wavers once.
And then there's Dwight, who saves Jim without even intending to. When Dwight comes into the room and sees a half-dressed Cathy with Jim, he doesn't pause or doubt his friend. He knows Jim would never cheat on Pam, so it doesn't even cross his mind. Bed bugs are truly the only thing he cared about. And a couple of deleted scenes would have revealed even more. One has Pam talking to Jim on the phone at the hotel.
Yes, we talk about this in our interview with Lindsay. We sure do. He tells his wife everything, but rather than being angry, Pam is amused. Mm-hmm. So, Kathy's character once again is used to show how strong Jim and Pam's relationship really is. Well, I wish more people would have had that in mind when they were watching the show, because as we talk about with Lindsay, man, there were some rough patches of fans
really coming for her. Yeah, even the week we interviewed her, she posted on her Instagram a screen grab of a comment someone made where they don't like Cathy. They think it's her. I know, I know. So still to this day, she gets it. Well, I ran into Lindsay recently in New York.
We ended up in the same audience of the same play. I know. And we talk about that in our interview. And what it made me realize, Angela, is that I have not shared my big news with everybody. That I am going to be doing a play. Oh my gosh. I can't believe we haven't talked about this. We have not talked about this. You shared, I think, on Instagram, right?
I shared on Instagram. But we haven't chatted about it. Here, this is huge news in the life and life goals of Janet Fisher. Yes, and of Lee Kirk. Oh yes, of course. This is my second project that I am doing, thanks to Lee Kirk and his amazing writing.
This fall, I am gonna be starring in a play called Ashland Avenue, written by Lee Kirk. It's going to be at the Goodman Theater in Chicago. I mean, that's a big deal. The Goodman Theater. That is a big, big deal. It is their 100th anniversary year. It's their centennial year.
We are kicking off their centennial year with this play. That's so great! So please come see me. Preview starts September 6th and then the play officially opens on September 15th. I will share all of that. I am coming. I can't wait to come and see you on stage lady. I can't wait. I know how much you love the theater and being part of that community. I've gotten to see you on stage twice. One in reasons to be happy and the second one was meteor shower. One was in New York. One was in San Diego. Now I'm going to see you in Chicago. Lady, you could have a little map with all the little dots of the different theaters you've been
in. That would be so fun. I have a request. What? Well then, will you do a play in London that I can come to? Oh, in the West End? Yes. Yes. Okay, let's put that out there. Okay, please, please.
Well, it's very exciting. Very exciting. I got offered a play in Dublin. And I couldn't do it. I know you could have come visited me in Dublin. That would have been amazing! I know it was a really good play, too, but it just didn't work out in my life, but, um... Well, as our new season and new chapters of our life begin,
I will follow you around and go to all of your theater performances. It's all I want to do now, truly. Well, this play, Ashland Avenue, it is funny, and it'll also just break your heart in a million pieces. It's a beautiful, beautiful... It's a work of art, and it'll also just break your heart in a million pieces. It's a beautiful, beautiful, it's a work of art. And I can't wait. Lee is such a good writer.
Yeah, it's got an amazing cast of local Chicago actors and it's being directed by the artistic director of the Goodman Theater, Susan Booth. I mean, she's incredible. She just directed Helen Hunt in Betrayal. So I can't wait. This is amazing. All right.
Well, you know, I ran into Lindsay as well, but it was at an office fan convention. She made me laugh so hard. She's so funny. She's just so funny. And I loved catching up with her. We'll talk about that when she comes on too. Well, you all might know Lindsay from her roles
in Get Him to the Greek, 21 Jump Street, and Hello Ladies. Most recently, you can catch her on the hit show Ghosts on CBS and HBO's Julia. And today, we dive in with her all about what it was like to play the foil to Jim and Pam's relationship. She has a lot to say about it. So we'll be right back after this break with Lindsay Broad. The all-new all-electric Can-Am Origin motorcycle takes you everywhere. Sleek power for the streets, deep adventure routes for the trails.
Discover your origin today. Learn more at CanAmMotorcycles.com. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.
Alcohol in select markets. See after details. Hi Lindsay! Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0. We are so excited to have you here today. Oh my God, I'm glad I finally made it. I know, this has been a long time coming. I know, because my first, when you guys got to my episodes, it was during the actor strike. Correct, yes.
It's very heartbreaking, because I waited a long time for you guys to get there. I couldn't believe it. Well, we are so excited to dive in and we're going to start with the question that we ask all of our guests, which is how did you get your role on The Office? Okay, so I got my role on The Office. It was like sort of a process because when they cast the role of Jordan at the end of, I think the seventh season,
I had auditioned for that and I had heard through some secret sources that I was one of the choices. I didn't end up getting it. Then the following summer, I was in Spain with my sister and for the first time, I brought no recording equipment with me, I brought no Spain with my sister, and for the first time, I brought no recording equipment with me. I brought no makeup with me. And I got an audition for the role of Carla,
which ended up being Cathy, and I made a tape. And my manager at the time was like, I can't send this tape in. You... This tape is... He had never done that. We had worked together for years. He was like, this tape is so he had never done that. We had worked together for years. He was like, this tape is so bad.
You're doing nothing. And also like, you're like sweaty, like you don't have on. And I was like, well, yeah, I'm in Spain. There's like no air conditioning. So he didn't end up sending my tape in. And then the day I got back, I guess he still hadn't found someone. So I went and I read in person with
Allison Jones and Ben and it was funny because I went in and I did more than I did on my initial tape and they brought me down down down till I was doing nothing aka what I did on my original tape. Your instincts? Yeah and I went to the laundromat and I was doing all of my laundry. And I got a text from BJ Novak that just said, yes, with an exclamation point, because he and I knew each other socially. And like an hour later, I got a call.
It was like 6 o'clock. And I had to be on set at 5 AM the next morning. What? What? And where were you at the time? Were you in LA, or were you on the East Coast? I was in Los Angeles. Yeah, I was living in Los Angeles.
And I remember I was like, well, I'm gonna go get some sushi and take an Ambien and go to bed. And I had an Ambien in my house that I saved for exactly that purpose in case I ever got a job last minute and knew that I needed to get a good night of sleep and I was gonna be too anxious to sleep. I had no idea that we did not cast the part of
Kathy until the night before. I did not know that. Oh yeah and I had just gotten back from this like trip with my sister and I was feeling like you know when you've been traveling and I hadn't been on my phone basically for like a week and I was like tan and I was just also in that like travel loopy space. And I remember I was sharing a trailer with Zach Woods and he just came up to me, he's like, how are you doing? And I was like, I'm kind of having a nervous breakdown.
And he was like, yeah, you'll be okay. I love that Zach was your pep talk guy. Oh, yeah, I love Zach. Yeah. Had you been a fan of the show before? Had you watched it? I had watched all of it. I had watched all of it from the beginning.
Oh yeah, I had watched all of it from the beginning. And it was the first time I had ever had a job on a show that I had watched. It was very surreal. It was the first time I had ever had a job on a show that I had watched. It was very surreal. It was very surreal. And what were you told about your character? Like, you got the job. You had 12 hours to prepare for this job.
But like, what did you know? Did you know that you were going to be on multiple episodes? Did you know? I knew nothing. Did you know you were going to be this wedge sort of maybe between Pam and Jim? So okay, so here's what I knew. I knew I was hired for one episode. I knew it had the potential to recur and I had absolutely no information other than the fact that the character was described as Scranton Hott. So I was like, okay.
And it's funny because- Please tell me you have a t-shirt that says Scranton Hot, Lindsay. No, but if somebody wants to make it for me, I'm wearing my t-shirts very large these days. I would like a larger and extra large. I think Scranton Hot is a phenomenal t-shirt idea. Isn't that so funny? I know my husband has been looking for a long time for like a good vintage March Madness t-shirt idea. Isn't that so funny? I know my husband has been looking for a long time for like a good vintage March Madness t-shirt for me. Uh-huh. But I was like, I can't wear this in public.
But anyway, yeah, so that was all I knew. And they would basically hire me, whatever, they would hire me at the last possible second for every episode. So I sort of just would like find out maybe like Friday night that I'd be back again Monday morning I always had a sense that I would be back But I never knew stressful. Oh, yeah, I never knew quite what was going on and Also, I don't know if you guys remember this but they would often Nobody quite knew... Looking back, I think the word they were looking for Kathy was basic, but that wasn't like a word in the vernacular at the time.
And they didn't really quite... They kept trying different things on for her at the table reads. So like there was an episode, like the trivia episode, where all of a sudden out of nowhere, I had like gone to an Ivy League school and was really good at trivia, and it turns out I was really secretly smart. And then that got cut. And then I remember talking to one of the writers
at the rap party, and they were like, "'Yeah, they just couldn't, "'they kept trying different things on, "'but it would never make it to the final draft.'" And then I think ultimately, I'm trying to remember when I figured out that I was gonna be the wedge, as you called it.
Was it in Pam's replacement? Like, was it? Because that was your first episode and Jim and Kathy have, you know, those scenes where they're laughing and she brings up Zoolander. And so there's a little bit of stuff happening there. Yeah. I remember her being like, okay, she's like kind of a cool girl. And there was all the discussions about whether like that whole episode, I think there's like a whole discussion
about whether or not I'm attractive. And yeah, I want to say the storyline with Cathy and Jim happened, I want to say like my, at the very end of my storyline. And I remember when I first realized it was going in that direction and I was just like, oh no. Oh no. I was excited because I was like, oh, this will be fun. I'll have stuff to do. But I just remember being like, oh no. They're going to come for me.
You knew. Yeah. But you know what? I feel like nobody really came for me in the moment. It was later on. It was sort of, you know, I'm sure you guys experienced too, that sort of like second wind,
like during the Netflix Comedy Central rerun era, and all of a sudden, that's when I started feeling a lot of attention. Yeah, I mean, we've said, we think that you, Rashida, and Chris Diamantopoulos should all like start a support group. And Rich Summer, yes of course.
Yes, because it wasn't easy. We actually, we got a fan question, a fan mail flurry of people wanting to know, did you and do you still get hate for hitting on gym? And Elizabeth B. from Buckley, Washington said, did you expect the backlash to affect your real life? So here's what I'll say. As far as I know, it doesn't really affect my real life because my real life I compartmentalize. I use the same last name as my kids.
I try to be pretty unassuming in my real life. So I don't know how much it bleeds over into how certain people see me or treat me. Occasionally if I meet somebody and they just like really don't like me despite the fact that I'm being very friendly, I'm always like in the back of my head like, is that what it is? But I will say the internet is just a really crazy place. And there was a moment, I tweeted something back when I used to be on Twitter when my dog was killed. And I had posted on Instagram that my dog had died. And there was a bunch of comments underneath being like, fuck you, Kathy, you deserve it.
And I had then tweeted about that, and then that kind of went viral. And then I still get engagement on this years old tweet, and so people always ask me about it. Here's what I will say. The internet is a crazy place. I've gotten used to people calling me Kathy. However, when I meet people in real life,
people are so excited. If people are big enough fans of The Office that they can recognize me, and again, I think I'm like sort of an unassuming looking person. I'm not like very flashy looking. So if they recognize me, they're like a big fan. People are so excited to see somebody from this show
that they are just incredibly nice. The internet is like a different story. Yeah, yeah. And that is so true. I mean, you and I ran into each other at this office fan convention last year and I hadn't been to the big, the office fan convention and everybody that comes there,
just their love for the show is so pure and wonderful. And it's like this show that brings people together from all over the world. And I left with such a positive experience from that. And they're excited to meet every single person. They wanna meet every single person that was on the show. And I just think that the fan base is really awesome in that way.
Yeah, it's really sweet. And I always think about, you know, there is this, I remember reading one of the actors from Lost who was saying, if you can just show up and like make somebody's day by showing up, then it's kind of hard not to do something like that. And I feel like the fan community of the show is so sweet. But the other thing that's so wild to me is how broad it is.
Yeah. Um, and I remember actually when I was cast on the show, I went to drinks with a friend of mine who's a comedy writer. And he was like, you're on Cheers. This is like being on Cheers. You know, like something that like people, and actually now I would say that, dare I say like it's a larger phenomenon than Cheers is that many years later. But I remember at the time being like, okay, this is something that will probably be in my obituary, which is like a very crazy thing to have associated with something that you did for, you know,
a period of like five months. And it's sort of immortal and like a very cool way. And I think I had a sense of that when it was happening. And still, it's really wild to me the degree to which it sort of like leads over into my personal life. Because again, I like don't make a show, you know, I have two kids. I never make it clear to anybody. Like I don't talk about being an actress or anything like that at their school. And it's always funny to me when eventually, like people have known me long enough
that they finally are like, can I ask you about? Like, let me talk to you about this. Like, I made it through all of last year, an entire year of preschool without anybody ever acknowledging it. And then it was funny because Helen Coleman, who played Isabelle, is a good friend of mine. And she came to my son's birthday party last summer.
And I remember mentioning this to a group of my friends, like my preschool mom friends. And they were like, we know. And I was like, see, that's the thing with me is that if you're just chill and you don't mention it for a full year, you never know who's going to show up at the birthday party. And they were all like, yeah. Oh, I love that. And you know, Lindsay, I felt like so protective of you when those comments came out on your post about losing your dog.
Because I know that, you know, we only had like two episodes together. We had the first episode and basically the last episode of your arc, and then I was on real maternity leave. But my experience of you was that you were such a kind and genuine person, and we're very protective of our office family. So it has bothered me that that happened. But I love hearing all of this about like getting to go to the fan convention and getting to feel the love of being part of this story.
Yeah, and I think it's especially like, I'll say that in New York City, you know, when I am walking around and it's happened like with my kids, when people spot you on the street and they want a selfie or you're like at Whole Foods and they just want a selfie, which was very confusing to my children for a long time, it's like the energy of it is so sweet. People love this show in such an intense way that it's really cool to be involved in something
that people have such an intimacy with this show. And it's a very, yeah, the parasocial thing is pretty cool. It's really cool to be involved in something that people have such an intimacy with this show. Yeah. And it's a very, yeah, the parasocial thing is pretty cool. Can we ask you about a few different moments in your episodes? Yeah. So, I was rewatching them last night and you're so good and you're so likable. Like, I mean, obviously once we get to Florida, if you're rooting for Jim and Pam, you are
like, hey, Kathy, whoa, whoa, whoa, pump the brakes. But in Pam's replacement, you're just like, just such a nice normal person in the office. But then there's the episode Gettysburg. And Lindsay, I did not realize in our tiny conference room scene, because half of everyone goes with Andy, right, on the field trip. And then there's only a small group of us left in the office and we end up in the conference room scene pitching our, you know, think outside the box ideas. And you were seated the whole time next to James Spader
in the back row. And I did not even realize that. And I always enjoyed our conference room scene so much. What was that conference room scene like for you? I just remember any time I was in that scenario where I was sort of like a fly on the wall, which worked because that's how she would have been as a temp, I just kind of sat back
and watched the show, if that makes sense. And I knew, you know, if I remember correctly, and you guys can correct me if I remember this incorrectly, they would do a straight take, right? Where they would get all the words that were on the page. And then they would get a take that was looser, where everybody was really playing around. And so it was always very fun for me,
especially that many years into the show, to watch this ensemble of people who knew how to play with each other. And I mean, the pool party episode really stands out. Like I remember that episode was really cool because everybody was in it, like for that week. I have a photo of all of us in the pool, like a selfie. You do?
Yes, I found it when we were- Oh my God, can you send it to me? Yes, I will. I was going through pictures for Jenna and I's book and I found it. And it's like the quality of it. One of the reasons we didn't use it is, I think I took it with like a flip phone.
I don't know. Yeah. But it is, it's us in the water. And that episode was so bonkers. I just remember that. I have no photos. I have no photos? I literally never took a single photo ever.
Oh, I will get that for you. I will go dig and find it. Isn't that crazy? Well, the pool party episode's so funny to me because I don't know what it was like for you guys, but I remember it was like a Thursday or a Friday and they were like, um, Lindsay wardrobe needs you. Um, wardrobe just needs you. They need to fit your swimsuit. I was like, my swimsuit? They were like, yeah, for the next episode. This is called The Office? What? They were like, the next episode is called Pool Party. And I was like, and meanwhile, like, I mean, I had been working, because I was in the background of all the
confessionals, I was always in the background and they shot those at the end of the day. And so I was always the first person in because I was the last person hired. So I was in the earliest to get my hair and makeup done. And then I was the last person out. So I was working. I didn't even have food in my refrigerator during that period of time. And I certainly wasn't working out. And I just remember being like, pool party. And when they went to my fitting, they were like, well, you can wear a one piece. And I was like, but she wouldn't wear a one piece, like integrity, like obviously she'd be in a two piece.
So I let them put me in like a bikini. And then I showed up to set and I think I was the only one in a bikini. And I felt so dumb. And then Charles McDougall, who directed that episode who I've since worked with, had a shot where he wanted me like getting up, I don't think they ended up using it,
but I had to like get up out of the pool right in front of the camera and then just like my butt walked by the camera. And I was just like, I can't believe this is happening. It's so funny, we talked to Ellie Kemper about that episode too, and she had the same reaction. She was like sat down at the table read and was like, pool party, huh?
Interesting. Yeah. Yeah. I thought the same thing because my character was quote unquote, eight months pregnant, but like fake pregnant. And I was like, pool party, okay. How are you guys gonna do this?
But they found a way, Lindsey, I don't know if you remember. Did you have a sarong? I feel like, did you have a sarong? I had, they wanted me in the background swimming laps with a kickboard. Oh, that's right. Yeah, at first they had me swimming laps, but they also had me put this fake belly in a maternity bathing suit. What they didn't factor in is that that fake belly absorbed water. And I literally was like, I'm going to drown. So then they got me a kickboard because I was like sinking. And then I would get out of the pool and it was as if I was peeing for like an hour as I walked around because that thing
was like leaking water. Well, I remember Mindy and I were in the background of somebody else's scene and we were supposed to be like, I don't know, doing something, and we decided we were going to be doing shots. But then we were basically just doing shots for like four, like pretending to do shots for four hours. So we just kept having to pee because we just kept drinking like whatever it was. But also when you, when you pretend to do shots for that long, you just start to feel a little loopy, like you start to feel a little drunk. I just remember doing that for like, and it was in that gorgeous mansion in Pasadena.
Yeah. Anyway, I have very fond memories of that episode, aside from the bathing suit. Thursday, May 8th is McHappy Day when every menu item purchased at McDonald's helps support families with sick children. So you can feel the good that comes from doing good, just from ordering. So if I order a Big Mac, I'm helping. Yup. What about a McFlurry?
10 piece chicken McNuggets and apple pie? You got it. Every single order helps. Join us at McDonald's for McHappy Day on Thursday, May 8th. Do good, feel good. A portion of food and beverage sales will support RMHC chapters and local children's charities across Canada. I have to go back to Pam's replacement
because there is a scene in Pam's replacement that I have to ask you about. So it's the scene where Dwight is going to see if Jim has an erection. Yes. How did you do it, Lindsay? This is like you were thrown into this ridiculousness of these two guys.
You were not breaking. Like you were. That was my first day. I know. It was? Yeah. I knew it was one of your very first days. And we did that scene for so long
because the two of them couldn't hold it together and you were in frame and you were holding it together. I'm like laughing off camera, watching all of it. And I remember on the day thinking, how is she doing it? She is so solid. She is amazing. Cause the whole time I was just like, don't get fired. Don't get fired.
Don't get fired. No, I would think I was just, well, here's a funny story about Pam's replacement. So I am sitting at your desk, right? You put me in your desk. And Matt's own, who was the DP of most of the series who directed a lot of the episodes towards the end, he was directing that episode. And I remember he kept saying to me, like every time the camera would roll, he would
sort of go, sit up straight? Sit up straight? And I got to this point where like I've always had bad posture. So I'm like, oh my God. And I kept just being like, I don't, I couldn't, I was like stretching my neck, like I could not possibly be sitting more straight. And I'm just the entire time like, I'm gonna get fired.
Like I'm gonna get fired because I can't sit up straight. And then all of a sudden, Rain was like, why are you so low? You look like a hobbit. You're like a hobbit down there. And that's when we realized because you were pregnant, they had lowered the seat because there had to be room for your belly. Oh my gosh.
Because you were actually pregnant. So that my belly could fit under the desk. So the seat was dropped all the way down. So it just looked like I was like under the desk, like this. And so I spent, I was so freaked out from that incident where I was convinced I was getting fired because I didn't know how to sit up straight
and I had such bad posture that I think I was just like, I was like in that zone where I was just, listen, I'm also a very serious actor, so I was just taking it off. Yeah, I don't know. I have no idea. And I get tagged in those videos all the time because I think the outtakes are on maybe the DVDs
or whatever. Yeah, the bloopers are on the DVDs and on YouTube. Yeah, so I'm always tagged in those and it's just so funny because all I remember from that day was just like, being like, I can't believe I made it here and now I'm gonna get fired. Well, you do break in after hours when there's that whole bed bug scene.
Yeah. You break so hard, you face plant it in the bed. Like you fall into the bed. I was exhausted. Yeah. But there's no way I could have got through that. No way. We just shot that scene for so long that I just, I feel like I was in that hotel room
for days. I mean, I was in that hotel room for days. I mean, I was in a hotel room for days. And the thing is, is it was shot in a real hotel room in the Valley and they had, I think they had Video Village, which is where everybody, all the producers and everybody sits and watches what's on the monitors. But because it was such a tight space,
they had like one monitor in the bathroom. And I think the only two people there, it was the director and Brian Baumgartner directed that episode. And... Warren and Halstead, I think they wrote that one. Warren and Halstead wrote that episode. And so they were the only ones there. And I just remember we shot that episode for what?
We shot those scenes for a very long time. So I think, not to like dispel anybody else's fantasy, but I think by the time we got there, I was just tired. You were loopy. I might have fallen onto the bed because I was just exhausted. Yeah. Lindsay, I have a memory of being there and watching some of those scenes. Do you have this memory?
How would I be there? Because you call, because Jim and Pam have a phone conversation. It's in the super fan episode. I think that I came up and did my off-camera dialogue. Did you? Maybe you just came to say hi. I have a strong memory of watching that bedbug scene
on the monitors. And I remember, like, calling you, Angela, and saying, I just watched one of the funniest things we've ever shot for The Office. Yeah. Yeah. But there is a whole Jim and Pam phone call. There is.
And it wasn't deleted scenes, but now it made it into this super fan extended cut. But it also was something that we rewrote and rewrote and rewrote. Like, once we got to this, like, set of episodes where Kathy is going to full throttle go for gym, I just, I think that's also why I have such a strong memory of being there, because I feel like there
was a lot of discussion about. Well, did John, did John loop you in? Here's what I- Yeah, like you- Here's what I remember. Taking a shower, like all this stuff, like I just remember it changing, changing, changing. Yeah, the initial draft of that script that I remember, and I wish I had it. I wonder if I do have it somewhere like in my files, but- I was looking at it this morning.
Oh, I would love to read it. The initial draft that I remember was a lot more ambiguous. And I know that there's, again, Google alerts I get on myself all the time, or that like we were going to do something. That is not my memory. My memory is that it was a much more ambiguous thing where you were kind of in Jim's perspective that it was a much more ambiguous thing
where you were kind of in Jim's perspective of like, is she hitting on me? Is she not hitting on me? Yeah, that's what I remember too, Lindsay. Yeah, so I remember. I don't remember, there was never in any draft, there was never a moment where Jim was gonna kiss Kathy or Kathy was gonna kiss Jim. No, there was a moment where he, there's the moment where Jim was gonna kiss Kathy or Kathy was gonna kiss Jim? No, there was a moment where he,
there's the moment where he says, like, hey, like, I think you're, I don't remember his exact lines, but he says something along the lines of like, hey, I feel like you're basically hitting on me. Yeah, he says, I think I just need to call this out. I'm married. And then Kathy's like, what do you think I'm doing?
Initially, in the script, and I'll remember this forever, cause it was very fun to shoot, Cathy said to him, oh my God, like, why does this always happen to me? Oh my God, I know you're married. And I remember shooting it and falling back on the bed, like, and John as Jim just being like, what do I do here? Like, he was sort of like doing his thing.
And then I kind of like threw myself back on the bed, and I'm like, this is so embarrassing. I don't understand why this keeps happening to me. Obviously, I know you're married, and it was much more ambiguous, and then there was the thing where then I take the shower, and I come in, and I'm like, I'm so cold. And the whole idea was, his head was just like,
is she or isn't she? What is going on? Yeah, and in the shooting draft, yeah, you say that. You're like, why does this always happen to me? And then Jim gets embarrassed and feels bad. He's like, oh, do whatever you want. I don't care. I just, you know, great.
You know I'm married, great. But wait, in the episode before, when you find out that you're going to Tallahassee with him, Kathy has a little phone call where she says to her friend. The tag. Yes. The tag where I'm holding my...
I don't know if this is too much for the office ladies, but I was holding the handle of my wheelie suitcase. And I remember I was just sort of holding the handle and I was just sort of like going like this while we were shooting it and they were like, Lindsay, you have to stop with your hand up and down like that. It's like really, really inappropriate. It just looks a little bit weird. Standards and practices is going to come if we, if we shoot that. Yeah. But so I think the initial episode was much more ambiguous, but John thought it was too ambiguous. So then set shut down for about four hours.
I swear to God, I was there. You might have been. You were a producer and if you were there doing your dialogue, Jenna, you would have been there. Part of this discussion. Yeah. Yeah. I don't even know how much anybody was part of it.
I feel like, yeah, my memories that John took the script, went to a hotel room and rewrote the script. And I want to say the bed bug thing wasn't, was the bed bug thing in the initial script, Angela? I don't think it was. It wasn't the shooting. I think it was because he needs Dwight to come in. That idea that he gets Dwight to run interference was in the original script. I know that. I knew Dwight was, yes. I knew that Dwight ran interference.
But specifically the smug bed bug, I'm not sure. No, and that was, yeah, I remember, I have a very distinct memory of that moment, the smug bed bug, because that was an improv, I believe. And my memory is that I remember thinking, wow, this just went a little off the rails. I feel like they're not gonna know what to do with me now because they've established that I'm so crazy
and the story line just got so crazy that unless they wanted to devote a whole bunch of time in the back half of the season to dealing with it, I wonder what they're gonna do with me. Well, the shooting draft, the narration that sets up each scene has zero wording in any way that Jim takes Kathy serious and is attracted to her.
Like at all, not once. It's like Kathy is enamored with him, but Jim doesn't like think there's any threat. And there's the scene of a phone call and I copy and pasted it so I brought it in. The phone call that Jim and Pam have, Pam says, is she still there? And Jim says, yep.
And then Pam says, she's obviously lying about the heat. And Jim goes, of course. And then Pam goes, aw, poor girl, really pathetic. And Jim says, yeah, it is. Pam goes on to say, well, I feel bad for her. I wish I could see your face. You're adorable when you're embarrassed. And Jim goes, yeah, it is. Pam goes on to say, well, I feel bad for her. I wish I could see your face. You're adorable when you're embarrassed. And Jim goes, ha ha.
Pam goes, okay, love you. Have fun with that. And Jim says, love you too. I will not. Then Jim hangs up the phone and Kathy says, fun to hear her voice. Scranton feels like a million miles away, right? And it says, Jim looks at Kathy with amused compassion.
So I remember this whole phone call thing, because as a producer, when we were talking about this storyline of this woman being in his hotel room, and Dwight seeing her in a towel or in her little outfit or whatever it was gonna be, I said, the thing for me that I don't want for the Jim and Pam relationship is some secret between Jim and Pam. Like, I want their relationship to be secure enough that like, I don't want people to wonder
if Jim told her what happened with Kathy. Right. Yes. Yeah, well that's like how my husband and I are. Yes. That's what we would in that scenario, you know, like we talk about stuff like that all the time. That was my pitch.
I was like, I want everyone to hear that Pam is totally secure with Jim being in this room with this woman. And so that dialogue that you just read, Angela, that was my pitch in the room, that we would. And I remember talking to Warren and Halstead about it and saying, like, this is how we're gonna make sure that people know that like Pam and Jim are okay.
Right. Yes, yeah. I just remember, I remember it being just the episode being much wackier than it initially was going to be. Yeah. Like it ended up taking a turn that was so wacky that I remember at the time thinking, I wonder if they're gonna know what to do with me after this because it was so cuckoo. Well, another episode I wanna ask you about before I forget is Tallahassee. That's the episode where Catherine Tate
has her big conference room moment. I love her monologue in that episode. What was it like to sit and watch her? Like, was that the coolest? She is so cool. I don't know how much, you guys worked together in the second half of the season. She is, first of all, so warm,
like one of the warmest, nicest people you could ever wanna meet. And she just has such unique rhythms. There's nobody exactly like her. She just has such unique rhythms. There's nobody exactly like her. So it was just really fun, especially to see somebody come in kind of so fully formed, which she did, and then just to watch her play,
especially because I don't think people in the US, for the most part, had been that exposed to her work. And so it was so fun watching somebody just come in and just be so, just bam on camera. Yeah. She just owned the room. We got a question from Isabella H. in Aptos, who said, what are some fun behind the scenes memories that you have from filming The Office?
Do you have any? Did you like our food? So I have a very specific memory of the breakfast orders and that there was Rashida style, which I want to say was egg whites with like tortillas. There was definitely a tortilla. But I remember always being like, the eggs are really oily and they're like, oh, you have to order it Jenna style.
And Jenna style was, they weren't allowed to just like, squirt a bunch of oil into the pan to scramble the eggs are really oily and they're like oh you have to order it Jenna style and Jenna style was they weren't allowed to just like squirt a bunch of oil into the pan to scramble the eggs I don't know if they scrambled it in something different but I know that if you wanted it not. Jenna style was butter no oil. Yes Jenna style was butter no oil so I used to get like the egg taco whatever I would call it Rashida, but then I would get Jenna style, which meant no oil for me, just butter. And the crafty was great because I would come in at 5 a.m. and I'd be there till like 7 p.m. So I had my foods that I would eat. I was doing a bunch of small meals. So I would
do my Siggy's yogurt and you guys always had really good berries. And then you always had perfect bananas and I would have a banana and almond butter. And I had like my very specific meals that I would have at certain times. And you had a good espresso machine. Yeah. That espresso machine was really good. We did.
Yeah, I had very specific, but the food. My memory though is always that at hot snack was 10.30 in the morning, and it would be like shrimp scampi. Something so weird at 10.30 in the morning and it would be like shrimp scampi. Something so weird at 1030 in the morning. But you know, if you got to work at 515 in the morning, you are starving by 1015. You're not gonna make it to lunch.
To this day, my body, like it hits 1030 and I'm like, are we having a meal? Like, what's our meal? Well, Lindsay, something that I know happened at the end of your run, you kind of mentioned this. You said you wouldn't find out if you were coming back the next week until the Friday before. Well, on your last episode, you rapped, and then you didn't come back. Yeah.
And you did not get the big send-off. Yeah. So I want to give it to you today. Thank you. All right everyone gather around. Gather around. Gather around. That is an episode and series wrap for Lindsay Broad. Let's give her a big applause for playing Kathy. Yay. Thanks guys. You're welcome. You know what we had a lot of people write in with love for you and what you brought to the role. Natalie M. from Kingwood, Texas says, please tell Lindsay that we love her and we see her
struggles for playing a character that comes between Jim and Pam. It's definitely not easy to play a part so well that brings people to believe you are that character, especially when the character can be a little on the evil side, ha ha. But she is a beautiful, loving lady who is definitely seen by the non-crazy side of the fandom. Oh, that's so sweet. Well, thank you guys. And if you guys, if anybody wants to see what I look like now, I am
I'm on Instagram at Lindsey Broad. That's probably where you can find me. Yeah, we'll link to it. Send me hate mail. No, we are going to share in our stories. And Lindsay, we just want to end the interview with something we do with our guests. It's the call sheet questions. Number one, what was your first job in entertainment? The pilot of Gossip Girl.
Oh! entertainment? The pilot of Gossip Girl. The first scene of the pilot of Gossip Girl. I am Melanie 91 who is following Serena around Grand Central Station with my phone. That's how I got my SAG card. Oh that's so good. Wow. Yeah it's a good one. Oh I'm gonna go look for it. My daughter just started watching Gossip Girl so we'll have to go look for it. Actually the thing that Netflix has up as like the preview is me following her around. So people like keep texting me about that. Oh, so fun. All right, question number two.
Do you speak any other languages? No. Do you play a musical instrument? I played the trumpet in middle school and high school because that's what my parents had in their attic. I played a cornet, which was a miniature trumpet. Can you still play that? I probably could, I could definitely play the scales.
Yeah. All right, what is a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved? New Orleans. I spent two months there filming 21 Jump Street and other than New York City, it's probably my favorite place on the planet. Yeah, I love New Orleans.
Such a great town. All right, what do you like to do on the weekends? We do a family movie night in our backyard and we have a screen and we have a projector and about once a month when the weather's good, we invite a bunch of families over and we just put it up online. This is what we're showing and everybody brings their blankets, we invite a bunch of families over and we just put it up online. This is what we're showing,
and everybody brings their blankets, and we have a popcorn machine, and then you have to bring a bag of candy to share. That is so fun. What is the last movie you guys did? The last movie we did, we closed the season with Home Alone in November, and we're reopening the season,
I believe, with Willy Wonka, the original. We show 80s and 90s movies, because it's good for the kids' attention spans to watch the slower paced movies. Yeah. So we'll open it again in March. I do love that you say this season's going to start. It's going to start.
Yes. We do it once a month. I love it. Lastly, what is your favorite midnight snack? So Costco has these chocolate covered strawberries in the freezer section. Wait, wait, wait. Is it called true fruit?
Yes. True fruit. True fruit. And the thing about true fruit is that the chocolate on true fruit is like the best chocolate I've ever had. It's so good, Lindsay. I have never had this.
Angela. I eat half a bag of it just walking around. I go to Costco on Monday nights when my kids are at their little play practice and I will eat like half a bag of them just walking around Costco. So now I have to take a break. Do you ever do the raspberries? Because I really like the chocolate covered raspberries and then- They only sell them at Target, right?
I think- Is that what it is? Costco has and True Fruit just recently I saw also makes like a dried fruit so it's not frozen. But their chocolate is so good. And it's like part white chocolate and part milk chocolate. Angela. Okay. I mean, you fruit and chocolate.
I'm in, I'm in. It's so good. It's specific though. It's like the brand is. Yep. It's true. Yeah. Well, Lindsay, this was so good. It's specific though. It's like the brand is. Yep, it's true. Yeah. Well, Lindsay, this was so wonderful.
And we are gonna share with folks how they can find you on Instagram. And thank you so much for being part of Office Ladies. We just have enjoyed this so much. Yeah, I hope I run into you ladies soon again. I'm gonna be out in New York in May and I'm gonna hit you up. I wanna go see, Let's see a show.
You want to see Glengarry Glen Ross with me? Yeah. Right. With Bob Odenkirk. Yes. OK. Message me. I know. Jen and I ran into each other. This is a funny story. I saw Jenna. I was seeing a play with a friend in the city and I see Jenna come in. And I said to my friend, I was like, I think that's Jenna.
And we had been talking about doing- Office ladies. About me coming on office ladies. Yeah. And I was like, I can't stalk this poor woman. Like she's probably just used to people coming up to her in the lobby and I'm just going to like make her anxiety. It's like I was going to just like give you that like nervous system spike. But then I was like, Jenna and then luckily, thank God, you were like Lindsay.
And I was like, oh my God. Thank God. But we had a cute run-in. I am kicking myself that we didn't get a photo together. Like why did Pam and Kathy not snap a photo together when we saw each other? I know, well in May. We'll do it in May.
We'll do it in May. And then maybe I'll see you. I think I'm gonna do the office fan convention this year. So if you're going, I'll see you. I would love to see you at that. That would be fun. We'll get dinner this time. Yes, let's. Ladies, what fun. Yes, I'll see you. I would love to see you at that. That would be fun. We'll get dinner this time. Yes, let's.
Ladies, what fun. Yes, thank you so much. Thank you, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey, and is produced by Jenna F Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.